[MUSIC PLAYING]
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
Honored to be joined
by Sebastian Junger who's
made amazing documentaries
such as "Restrepo."
His newest one is called
"Hell on Earth" about Syria.
And he's also the author
of the book called "Tribe."
So let's give Sebastian
a warm Google welcome.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Thank you.
Thank you.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: So
we're going to start off
talking about "Hell on Earth."
Maybe we can go
into why you decided
to jump into that topic, what
inspired you to get involved?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: So I became a
war reporter in the early '90s.
I went to Sarajevo, to Bosnia.
This is of course before the US
was involved as a peacekeeping
force.
And I continued covering civil
wars throughout the '90s.
I first went to
Afghanistan in 1996.
I watched as the
Taliban prepared
to overrun Kabul and Jalalabad,
and then again in 2000.
Then I was in Sierra
Leone and Liberia.
Most of my experience
as a war reporter
has been with the local
population and in wars
that the US wasn't involved
in and wasn't thinking about.
And then my colleague
and I, Tim Hetherington,
spent time with US forces
in Eastern Afghanistan
in Kunar Province and made a
documentary called "Restrepo."
We went to the Oscars.
We were nominated for an Oscar.
We didn't win.
A few weeks later
we were supposed
to go on assignment to Libya
to cover the Libyan civil war.
It was part of the sort
of Arab Spring uprisings
that were so interesting and
complicated, really complicated
moment for the Arab world.
At the last minute
I couldn't go.
Tim went on his own and he got
killed in the city of Misrata.
He was hit by
fragments from a mortar
fired by Gaddafi's forces.
And he bled out in the back
of a pickup truck from a wound
that I think didn't
necessarily have to be mortal.
No one around him
knew what to do.
Not the rebels and not
the other journalists
had any medical training at all.
He just bled out a few
minutes from a hospital.
And after that, I decided
to stop war reporting.
But Syria turned into sort
of the worst case scenario.
I mean all the Arab
Spring countries went
through what they went through.
Tunisia ended pretty well.
Libya is still pretty rocky
but it's quieted down.
Syria was just full-on
bloodbath, 400,000 people dead
at this point,
millions of refugees,
a lot of international interests
converging on the problem
and making it worse.
And so my colleague
and I, Nick Quested,
decided we really had to
examine the case of Syria.
How did it start?
What went wrong?
Why is there a civil war there?
And particularly, how did
ISIS come out of this?
Syria is the only country that
produced something like ISIS.
ISIS really is just sort of
remarkable in its depravity
and its violence and its
pretension to religious purity.
And so we just felt it was an
important thing to explain.
And of course you
want to make something
that helps people come to a
good decision about what to do.
And that's always in the
back of any journalist's mind
or filmmaker's mind.
So that's how we wound
up focusing in Syria.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Gotcha.
And so you used
Syrians on the ground
to record your
footage and whatnot?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Yeah, I mean
for the first time in my life
I made a film and wasn't
on the ground shooting.
In fact I didn't even
leave the United States.
I was writing a book.
I was writing my book
"Tribe" and promoting it.
Nick went overseas.
It was a suicide mission
to go into Syria itself.
They were kidnapping journalists
and cutting their heads off
on camera.
I mean, danger on the
battlefield is one thing.
The risk of being kidnapped
and executed is an entirely
different kind of risk that
really almost no one has
the stomach for, and
I certainly don't.
So what we were able to do,
what Nick was able to do
was along the
Turkish-Syrian border,
he found people,
fixers, and people
who had family in
Syria, friends in Syria,
he found people that
knew people in Syria who
were documenting their own
civil war with cameras.
And we started working with
and we would get cameras
to people in there.
We started working
with people who
were stuck in the Civil War,
either just the civilians
or they were Syrian
cameramen who
wanted to document what was
happening to their country.
We started working with
them sort of remotely.
We would get thumb
drives into them.
We'd get cameras into them.
We'd give them
shooting instructions.
And then we'd get this
material back out.
And it was a very, in
some ways, awkward way
to make a film compared to just
being on the ground shooting.
But it also had enormous
advantages in addition
to the fact it was
just safer for us.
But it had other sort of
creative advantages as well.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Can you
talk about the backdrop
to Syria, like the
different political entities
that are involved
right now in civil war?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER:
Yeah, I mean it's
super complicated of course.
And Nick really was the
expert about that stuff.
I mean he did 30-some
trips over there
and he really got into the
weeds with Syrian politics.
He didn't successfully
completely
drag me into the weeds with him.
But from what I
understand, of course
you've got the Assad regime.
It's backed by Iran,
heavily aided by Hezbollah,
and backed by the
Russians, by Putin.
So no, you're not going
to topple the regime that
has friends like that.
Assad's not going anywhere.
In the beginning of the war, the
Free Syrian Army was largely--
it was the product of a popular
uprising, an uprising that
was protesting not only
the deep, deep corruption
of the Assad regime but also
the just unspeakable brutality
of the security forces
that kept them in power,
security forces
that were completely
OK with detaining teenage
boys who had sprayed graffiti
on a wall--
down with Assad, just
something like that--
completely OK with
detaining 15-year-old boys
and torturing them to death.
That was how the
revolution started,
with parents whose
boys had been detained
and were in a police
station, parents
massing in front of
the police station
demanding the release
of their children,
and finally storming the
police station to save them,
and then the security forces
opening fire on the parents.
That's how the
civil war started.
And sometimes in this country
what I hear from people is.
it's crazy.
It's a civil war.
If those people want
to kill each other,
you can't tell them apart.
Just let them kill each other.
You have to
understand, people have
to understand how
these things start.
They start with obscenities
like that situation in Daraa.
It's the town of Daraa.
So the FSA came out of that.
And of course the
longer a war goes on,
the more chance you have of
a popular and more or less
democratic movement
metastasizing,
having some parts
of it metastasize
into radicalization,
into really sort
of like vicious
anti-Western thought.
It becomes just as inhuman
and cruel as the regime
they're protesting.
So one of the arguments, one
of the moral and practical
arguments for intervening
early on in civil wars
is that keeps that kind of
radical cancer from starting.
And once it's started,
it's really hard to stop.
I mean just like with
cancer in the human body,
it's really, really
hard to stop.
And that's what happened.
The FSA splintered.
Some groups got
really radicalized.
Al-Qaeda came in.
And eventually ISIS was
sort of incubated and born
in the vacuum in Iraq
after the US withdrawal
and migrated into Syria
and really took a foothold,
got a foothold in Syria.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
In the documentary
you follow a particular family.
Can you talk about how you guys
got connected to them and maybe
an update on what the
family's doing now
if you're still in contact?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Yeah, so it's
two family of brothers, Marwan
and Radwan.
One was a garage mechanic,
another at a little cell phone
shop in Aleppo.
And they were
pushed out of Aleppo
by the fighting to a
town called Manbij.
ISIS took over Manbij.
They were living
under ISIS control
with their children, their
wives and their children.
And the Russian Air Force
and Assad's air force
was bombing Manbij
pretty regularly.
And so what Nick managed to
do was he knew the brother.
He knew a third brother
that was actually in Turkey.
And he said, "Listen,
would you think
those families would
like to document life
under ISIS for us?
We'll pay them and
they'd shoot for us."
So they agreed to.
And so we got them
a camera, like
a very nondescript, low
profile Samsung 7 cell phone
camera basically, the
kind that everybody
has so they're not calling
attention to themselves.
And they self-documented.
They documented their lives
under ISIS, the conversations
they had about if they
should try to escape,
what are the risks of escaping?
And they documented
the escape itself.
They were basically
under a tarpaulin
in the back of a truck driving
through ISIS checkpoints
through no man's land into
FSA territory, eventually
into Turkey.
And keep in mind, just
imagine, those of you
who have children, doing
a journey like that,
knowing that if you get
stopped at a checkpoint
and they pull the tarpaulin
back and they discover you,
you and your family will be
lined up and machine gunned.
That's what the stakes were.
And they documented all this.
And thank God they
got out safely.
They got to Turkey.
Nick met them in Turkey
and got to meet them
and then started
shooting them himself.
And then they continued
on with their camera
onto a Zodiac, a rubber Zodiac
trying to get to Greece,
and the last moment
were turned back
by the Turkish Coast Guard.
So some of the most
extraordinary parts of the film
are parts that just
this family shot.
And really, it's a whole new way
of thinking about filmmaking.
Even if we'd been
able to go in there,
it would have been
like a Westerner
with a video camera in
the middle of this very
intimate family situation.
It would have altered it.
It would not be the reality
that you're seeing here.
And so really there is something
to be said for asking people
to self-document as long as
you can trust that they're not
manipulating you.
And that's the only
downside to it.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
And there's a scene
when one of the families, the
husband and wife are talking
and he was making a decision
if they should flee or not.
And they were arguing
right in front
of like six of their children.
And it just really
hit home about
how terrible the crisis is.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Yeah, I
mean they're stuck in Turkey,
so they're safe, but
they're miserable.
And they're arguing about
whether to risk the boat
passage.
And you all know,
there are a lot
of people drowned, a
lot of loss of life
on these Zodiacs
of people trying
to get from North Africa to
Europe from Turkey to Greece.
And the wife is like--
the mother is saying,
one big wave and I
lose all my children.
And he is saying, OK, but
at least we'll die together.
And right now we're
stuck in Turkey.
Our children have
no future at all.
I say it's better that we
gamble on giving them a future
or we die together
and that's God's will.
And the husband eventually
won the argument.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: There's
an argument in the West
that during all this chaos
that the people who are leading
should stay there and they
should fight or something.
But I think after
watching this documentary
you realize how much
of a terrible situation
they're in right now.
For the people that are
caught in the diaspora,
did you talk to
any of them to see
if they're willing to go back
to Syria or are they thinking--
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: I mean
most of the refugees
that Nick had contact
with want to go back
to Syria as soon as they can.
I mean, the people that
were displaced by the fire
up in Sonoma, wherever
they're living right now,
they don't want to stay there.
They want to go back to
their homes, rebuild.
You know, that's just the
normal human thing, and likewise
with refugees.
Not everybody-- the West is
pretty appealing frankly.
And I mean some
percentage of people
are going to want to stay here
to enjoy the life that we're
here for.
I mean, they're the same
as us, so some people
will want to stay.
And frankly, the immigrant
population of this country
has contributed
enormously to our society.
My father's an immigrant.
In fact, he's a war refugee.
He was a two-time war refugee
from the Spanish Civil War
and then the Nazis in France.
My first wife was an
immigrant from Bulgaria.
This country's
better off for having
those people, those good
people in our borders.
And so I think to the
extent that some people will
want to stay, I think
there's probably
a net gain for us and
obviously for them.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Can you talk
about the organization of ISIS?
Because when I watched
the documentary,
I just thought it was maybe
just a couple-- like a group
of people who are just rebels.
But it seemed like they're
setting up their own state
inside of Syria.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: I mean the
interesting thing about ISIS
as opposed to al-Qaeda
is that they really
controlled territory.
They had oil refineries.
They were setting up
a taxation system.
They were running schools and
every aspect of a functioning
modern society.
They're repaving roads.
They were doing
all the things you
would expect the state to
do in exchange for giving
the state taxes.
They were providing
those goods and services.
And that made them
really different
from any other terrorist group.
And they are a terrorist
group obviously.
And they really controlled
quite a bit of territory
in Iraq and Syria, in
Northern Iraq and Syria.
And so they had a [INAUDIBLE]
civil administration,
a military hierarchy,
their leader.
The sort of supreme leader
was named al-Baghdadi.
No one's sure if he's
alive or dead right now.
I think people think
he's probably alive,
but obviously he's had
better days than right now.
And they're really being rolled
up pretty quickly in Syria.
Which doesn't mean that
their threat is over with,
but what they proclaim
to be the caliphate--
they declared the
caliphate in the area
that they controlled,
harking back
to the sort of glory days of the
Arab world of the Muslim faith.
And that dream, or
nightmare, has died.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Now
in the current situation
you have Kurds and you
have FSA involved, whatnot.
If ISIS is pushed
out, does the FSA
have enough strength the
actually control the country?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER:
Right, I forgot.
I lost track of my list of
players in this situation.
So the Kurds are an
autonomous tribal group.
And their population spills into
Turkey, into Iraq, into Iran,
into Syria.
They dream of having
an independent Kurdish
state, which of course is
extremely threatening to all
of the states that they're part
of, because those states don't
want Kurdish-controlled
territory carved out
of their national
borders, particularly
if Kurdish-controlled territory
happens to have a lot of oil
in it, which some of it does.
So it's all extremely delicate.
The Kurds have been very, very
useful allies, helpful allies
in fighting ISIS.
But recently they
turned around and voted
for independence, which
completely freaked out Iraq.
And now they're fighting with
their former allies in Iraq.
I mean, there's
potentially a regional war
involving the Kurds and all
of the different nations
around Kurdish
territory that don't
want them to have independence.
And so let's see,
who else is involved?
It's also a major confrontation
between Sunni and Shia Islam.
So when we invaded
Iraq, the Sunni minority
had political and military
control of the country
under Saddam Hussein and
oppressed the Shia majority.
When we came in, we got
rid of Saddam Hussein.
We started a
de-Ba'athification program,
The Ba'ath Party was the sort of
nationalist party under Saddam
Hussein.
So he purged the military,
the schools, the universities,
right down to very
low-level jobs.
He purge them of all Ba'athists.
Of course a lot of those
people were perfectly decent
people who were stuck in a
system where you had to be--
like under communism
in Eastern Europe,
you had to be part of
the Communist Party
in order to even get a
job sweeping the streets.
Being in the party
doesn't mean anything.
But we purged all those
people and basically created
an unemployed and
very bitter population
who were then oppressed--
I mean oppressed, murdered,
rounded up, tortured,
killed, murdered by
the Shia government
that we put into
power in Baghdad.
Oddly, the Shia government had
of course very strong relations
with the Shia government
in Iran who's our enemy.
So no matter what we
did we were creating
a contradiction in
our policies, almost
sort of brilliantly
contradictory policy.
It would be hard
to actually set out
to be as contradictory
as we were.
So a lot of these
disenfranchised Ba'ath Party
leaders and generals and
officers and party leaders
and all that eventually
started the Sunni insurgency,
partly to protect the Sunni
population from the Shia who
were beating up on them.
And eventually
when President Bush
started negotiating a
US withdrawal from Iraq
and then handed that
off to Barack Obama, who
sort of finished the job, in
the vacuum of our withdrawal,
the Shia government--
the Shia forces sort of
had free reign to really
abuse the Sunni population.
And at that moment, ISIS was
formed as a civil defense force
to protect the Sunni population.
And what they offered
was a pathologically
extreme and virulent
vision of Islam
in exchange for protection.
And so it was born
in Northern Iraq.
It was born in Iraq.
And when the Syrian Civil
War really got going,
they saw an opportunity.
They migrated into Syria, took
territory, came back into Iraq
and overran, I think,
five Iraqi Army divisions,
then took all their weapons.
And they just started sort
of bouncing back and forth
between Syria and Iraq, grabbing
more and more territory,
taking over oil fields,
creating oil revenue, tens,
hundreds of millions
of dollars of revenue
now being generated
by this machine,
which could then pay for
more arms and more jihadis.
The whole thing
sort of snowballed.
And it wasn't until
recently that ground forces
were able to start
to roll that back.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
Now you mentioned
in the documentary
Assad kind of jump
started some of the
radicalism inside of Syria
when he released certain people.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Yeah, so Assad
knows that Western forces have
a sort of soft spot for
democratic movements,
because we're democracies.
And when people rise up
in Tunisia or in Egypt
or wherever, or in
Ukraine or wherever--
it's happened in many places--
the Western powers
are like, oh great,
a democratic movement
will overthrow
this despotic regime,
another spot of light,
sunlight in the world.
We're for that.
Of course Assad knows that.
So the FSA, they
really were quite
democratic and idealistic
when they started.
And Assad knew that
that would be absolutely
irresistible to
Western powers who
want to arm them and
give them the capability
to topple his regime,
much like we armed
the Afghan fighters
in the 1980s so they
could fight the Russians
who had invaded them.
It's sort of the same idea.
So what he did--
but he also knew that the West
was scared of Islamic radicals.
And he had a lot of
Islamic radicals,
I mean straight up
terrorists, in his jails.
So what did he do?
He released them.
He released the most violent and
radical Islamists in his jails
and seeded the SSA
with Islamic radicals,
and then was able to
say, look, if you topple
them-- said to the
world, if you topple me,
this is what you get.
You basically get
al-Qaeda in Damascus.
So careful who you
arm over there.
So he sort of ruined
the party basically
by letting these
radicals out of jail.
And he'd much rather fight
al-Qaeda in his own country
than fight a democratic movement
that's armed by the West
in his own country.
I mean, that is not a
fight he's going to win.
And so as soon as he did that,
then the Russians could say,
we're all fighting
terrorists together.
And then they had their
rationale for bombing
and on it went.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: So for
people who are on the ground,
they talk about what they
see as a possible end
game for this conflict.
I mean, there's so
many different pieces.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: I mean,
the war in Afghanistan
started when the
Soviets invaded in 1980.
We're coming up on 40 years now.
And it's still at war.
And if we pulled
out, if we completely
pulled out of Afghanistan,
the war will get worse.
I mean that's the sort of
weird delusion of the left
is that if you pull US
forces out of a country,
things will get better.
And actually what happens
is the civilian death
toll will get dramatically
worse if we pull out.
It may be that the
Syrian conflict
does not, within the next
couple of generations,
have a solution.
It's entirely possible.
If there is a kind of
tentative stability
that allows for a drop in
the suffering of civilians,
it will be, I think, a
de facto partitioning
of the country where the
front lines kind of stabilize
and the country is
divided through sort
of ethnic and tribal
divisions that
figure out how to have a kind
of stability, like in Bosnia.
I mean in Bosnia that was helped
by the Dayton Peace Accords.
But basically it solidified
front-line positions that
had evolved during the war.
And it sort of solidified
them as a permanent solution.
And something like that
may happen, I don't know.
Or it could easily
keep going on.
The problem is you
have Shia versus Sunni.
You have this sort of weird
axis of Putin, Assad, and Iran
and Hezbollah versus the West.
You The Kurds are in there.
The Turks, I mean,
the Turks are making
some incredibly
troubling decisions
about their own country and
about their foreign policy.
So you have these unbelievably
problematic and self-interested
parties.
And there's a huge
amount of oil, right?
There's a huge amount
of oil in these areas.
Like what else could you
throw into a situation
to keep it going
for a long time?
I mean Afghanistan
doesn't have oil.
I mean, no one really
cares about Afghanistan.
It's not like the
international community
is dying to get its hands on--
whatever.
I mean, Syria is a nightmare
compared to Afghanistan,
and Afghanistan is still
going on after 40 years.
So I think one of the
things that could happen
is a regional war that
kills a million people.
I mean, that's
entirely possible.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Very cheery.
So when you're working
this whole entire project,
what were you main takeaways?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: The
first thing I wanted to do
is disabuse people of the
idea that when a country slips
into civil war it's somehow
a sort of broad moral failure
by the population that they
somehow like violence and can't
keep themselves from
killing each other.
That's just not how
civil wars work.
That's not how it
worked in our country.
Everyone forgets, we
had a civil war too.
That's not how it worked in
our country in the 1860s.
It's not how it works.
The vast majority of people
are good, decent people
who don't want to be
killing their neighbors.
It doesn't take very
many psychopaths
and nationalists and
power-hungry politicians
to tip a country into civil war.
It really doesn't take a lot.
Likewise in street
demonstrations,
it doesn't take a lot
of sort of Molotov
cocktail-throwing
anarchists to turn
a completely reasonable street
demonstration into a riot.
It really doesn't take a lot.
And so I wanted
people to understand
that the people of Syria or
Bosnia or wherever it is,
they're just decent people.
They're people exactly like us.
And when they flee
with their children,
they're not trying
to take advantage
of the bounty of
the West and take
advantage of our generosity.
Fleeing their country is
incredibly scary and dangerous.
It's the last thing any
reasonable person would
want to do with their children.
And yet they're doing it
because they know if they
don't, they're going to die.
That's what an immigrant
refugee population is.
And the other
thing I wanted to--
there are two other things
I wanted to explain.
First of all, some
of this came out of--
some of it we can't control.
The countries have internal
dynamics of civil wars.
We can't play god.
Not everything that
happens in the world
is because we did or
didn't do something.
But I have to say, our
invasion of Iraq in 2003
introduced in a huge amount
of instability and violence
and death into that
part of the world.
I'm not defending the
Saddam Hussein regime.
Of course he was
unspeakably evil.
But just for the
purposes of history,
we killed something
like 100,000 civilians.
We introduced
violence as a norm,
a new norm in Iraqi society, and
made some incredible blunders,
like de-Ba'athification.
And when you traumatize
a society like that,
it's like traumatizing a child.
It will act badly.
I mean trauma produces a
result, not a good one.
And then the
withdrawal-- then if you
invade a country and
kind of break it,
then you kind of
should stay there.
And we didn't do that either.
I mean in Afghanistan in the
'80s, we armed the Afghans
to the teeth so they
could fight the Russians--
which is arguably the
right thing to do--
spent a huge amount of
money giving them weapons.
And when the Russians
pulled out, what did we do?
We didn't care
about the Afghans.
We pulled out.
We didn't stay to build schools
and build bridges and help.
No, all we were doing,
all we were interested in
was killing Russians.
We actually didn't care
about the Afghans, at least
not judging by the money
allocated by this nation
afterwards.
So I wanted to make
the point that we
can be judgmental and whatever
about those crazy people
over there that have
their crazy civil war.
We are part of it.
And America has done enormously
good things in the world too,
including stopping fascism
during World War II.
My father grew up in Europe.
He's alive because-- I mean
his homeland survived--
France survived because of us.
I mean, he made that very
clear to me when I was young.
So we're an enormous power
for good in the world as well.
But we need to own our mistakes.
And I would like to propose Iraq
was a mistake, in that sense.
And finally, the public
use of violence by ISIS--
I mean taking people
into the town square,
pouring gasoline over them,
and burning them alive,
putting them in steel cages,
groups of men in steel cages,
and then dangling them over
a swimming pool by a crane
and then slowly dropping
them into the water
and watching them drown, with
underwater cameras to record
it, that is pure evil, right?
It's an evil of the sort that
is absolutely unacceptable
and I'm glad they're being
eradicated from the planet,
but it's the kind of evil
that every society, including
our own, has indulged in.
I mean people commit
public violence in order
to intimidate other people.
And you don't have to go very
far back in American history
to find public violence.
I mean the lynchings of
black men in the South,
I mean those men
could have been easily
killed quietly in the
dead of night and buried.
That's how people
commit murder, right?
They do it quietly and secretly.
That's not what happened
in the American South.
The murders were done in
an intentionally cruel way
in the middle of town.
I mean, there were ministers
who would let church out
early so that the congregation
wouldn't miss the lynching.
That's an attempt to
intimidate the population
just like ISIS was doing.
So one of the points
I wanted to make
is that ISIS must be
condemned, but in the context
of acknowledging that
every society has
used that kind of violence.
And we need to
acknowledge that dark--
in condemning the
dark side of ISIS,
in the same moment
we have to actually,
to be intellectually honest,
acknowledge the dark side
that we're capable of, and
thank God have transcended.
But we can't forget that.
We can't be too sanctimonious
that they're somehow inherently
different than we are.
You go back two
generations in this country
and they're really not.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
Now the documentary
showed how a person got
radicalized and joined ISIS.
I guess there is a
theory that people
join these groups because of
lack of economic opportunity.
And some other people
think, no, it's not that.
It's for other causes.
Where do you land on that?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER:
There's a whole range
of reasons to join ISIS.
If you're Syrian and ISIS rolls
into your hometown in pickup
trucks, a really compelling
reason to join ISIS is that
they'll kill you if you don't.
So there's that to some
sort of economic opportunity
in those areas for
disenfranchised people
that feel like they need to join
the winning team to survive.
And then if you move to
the European population,
why would--
I mean, it was mostly
middle-class kids
that joined ISIS.
Why would a middle class kid
in Europe of Arab descent--
but not an immigrant,
not a refugee,
someone who was born in France
or in England of Arab descent,
middle-class kid who's in school
and university, whatever--
why would they join ISIS?
They are not economically
desperate people actually.
That's not the kind of
people who would join ISIS.
They're too busy working.
They're too busy trying to
work and with their families.
It's really middle-class kids.
And teenagers are particularly
vulnerable to sort
of utopian visions.
And ISIS wasn't trying to
lure them in to their movement
by showing beheading
videos, because then you
only get the psychopaths.
And psychopaths can be
useful, but you can't have
a whole army of psychopaths.
There just aren't
enough of them.
So what they did to lure
people is to give them
a vision of a utopia.
And so they had these videos
of incredibly high production
values showing a family
in ISIS territory
having a picnic by a
lake, things like that,
just this sort of
utopian, idealized vision
of life inside the caliphate.
And also just the whole
idea of the caliphate
is finally standing
up to the West
and reclaiming this very
real, sort of historical,
sort of lost golden
age of Islam,
and this sort of
very real dignity
that the Arab world had
in regard to the West.
That had been lost.
And they're very conscious
that it's been lost.
And totally reasonable,
they want to reclaim it.
We would too.
And so what they
do is these videos
that they put out
there were showing
in a very glowing sort
of light this utopia
that you can come join.
And also, young people want to
be something bigger themselves,
greater than themselves.
There's a great band,
Queens of the Stone Age,
and they have lyrics
to one of their--
I can't remember the
name of the song.
The lyric is, "She
wanted something
to die for to make it
beautiful to live."
That's ISIS.
I mean that's the
appeal of ISIS.
That's the appeal
of, in the 1930s,
going over and fighting
the Spanish Civil War.
And that's exactly what's going
on with those kids in Europe.
And then they get
over there and they
realize it's a
complete lie and it's
a horribly abusive and
depraved organization.
But then it's too late.
Then they're basically stuck.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Now the US is
increasingly our involvement.
I heard recently we have some
troops now on the ground.
And I guess we're
working with the Kurds
to a degree or something.
Do you see US
involvement increasing?
We're going to have more
soldiers as time goes on?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Yeah, there's
a Marine expeditionary unit
there.
There's a bunch of 155s over
there, artillery over there.
They've got aircraft flying
out of Northern Iraq I guess.
I don't really know
the tactical details,
but yeah, there are
US forces over there.
They're focused
on defeating ISIS.
I don't know
exactly what they're
going to do when ISIS is
gone and different militia
groups that they were allied
with, including the Kurds,
start fighting with each
other to control the areas
that ISIS used to occupy,
particularly the oilfields.
So are US forces then going
to become peacekeeping forces?
I'm not sure exactly
what's going to happen.
I'm not sure the
administration knows
exactly what's going
to happen if Turkey
decides that parts of those
areas really should be Turkey.
They feel that Mosul
is a Turkish city.
Mosul's in Northern Iraq.
How's that going to go?
There's an expeditionary unit
in between Turkey and Mosul.
It's going to have to stay
there to keep Turkey from trying
to claim a piece of--
I mean, it's a huge mess.
And the administration right
now, the Trump administration
is juggling an awful lot of
very complicated situations.
I hope they have the
bandwidth to figure out
a wise course of action, a
wise strategy in that area.
I hope they do.
I wouldn't say it's
likely that they do,
but I hope they do,
I mean for our sake
and for the sake of
the people over there.
There's a lot of innocent people
still stuck in that country.
They really don't
need Western powers
making more mistakes
with that area.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Now
in your documentary,
you're limited because you have
to air it on cable and whatnot.
Were there things
that you wanted
to include in the documentary
but didn't have enough time
to do?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Oh, anytime
you make a 90 minute film,
you really feel like you should
have made a hundred minute
film.
This is actually
a hundred minutes.
Every time you make a
hundred minute film,
you think it should have
been 120 minute film.
The truth is, a hundred minutes
is about as much time as people
can kind of really
concentrate on
something difficult. And
this is definitely difficult.
So yeah, there's always
stuff that drops out.
The beauty of the
internet is that you
can put that content that
didn't go into the film,
you can put it on a
website and say, oh,
if you want a more expansive
story about this refugee
family, here it is.
And so we made these
sort of mini films
that broadened some
of these topics
that we had to sort of
confine and cut short.
So all that stuff
sort of lives online.
And that's actually a
kind of pretty cool use
for that material.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Do we
have any audience questions?
We'll get you a
mic in the second.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for
taking the time here.
I'd never heard that thing about
the hundred minute attention
span and was wondering
where you got that from?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: I
mean, that's not data.
That's not research.
It's just that's my sense
from watching a lot of films
and from making a lot of films.
A hundred minutes seems to
be just about the limit.
I mean you can go to
two hours, whatever.
But if you go to
two hours, trust me,
the audience will know
you've gone to two hours.
And you really don't want
your audience thinking
about how long the film is.
As soon as that--
you know what I mean?
It's like on a first date
you don't want your date
thinking, wow, we've been
having dinner for two hours.
That's not a good sign.
Same with filmmaking.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted to
understand your viewpoint
on ISIS vis-a-vis the Taliban.
They seemed to have
had similar structures
in terms of carving
out territory,
providing basic services,
promises and the rest.
But ISIS is a bit more
brutal of course it seems.
So what's your take?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER:
Oh yeah, I mean,
the Taliban were conducting
public executions.
They were stoning adulterers in
the sports arena, for example.
But the Taliban weren't
a terrorist organization.
I mean, they were terroristic
towards their own population.
I think they're
extremely abusive.
And so are a lot of
right-wing regimes as well.
Brutality is brutality.
But they weren't
attacking the West.
And from the West's
perspective--
and we are Westerners, right?
From our perspective, you become
a terrorist when you attack us.
AUDIENCE: Weren't they
housing Osama bin Laden--
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Well yes.
AUDIENCE: --and thus--
it seemed like they
were housing Osama bin Laden.
And so it was this default
attack on the West.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER:
Absolutely they were,
and that was problematic.
But they themselves,
they started
in the madrassas of Pakistan.
Their entire focus was bringing
their vision of sort of pure
and, we would argue, radical
Islam to Afghanistan.
That was the their entire focus.
They weren't trying
to use Afghanistan
as a base to attack the West.
Now they did host bin
Laden and al-Qaeda
is a terrorist organization.
And they finally really
got our attention.
I mean it took a while to
get our attention, right?
I mean al-Qaeda
attacked us a few times,
and we kept sort of like,
oh, OK, that didn't hurt.
That didn't hurt too much.
I mean, it took a few tries
before we actually really
focused on them.
And of course that was 9/11.
And after 9/11 happened,
the United States was like--
I mean George Bush said
to the Taliban leadership,
turn over al-Qaeda.
Turn over the
al-Qaeda leadership,
we will not invade your country.
We'll actually come and help
you, because you need help.
If you don't turn them over,
we will come after them.
And you will become
our enemy as well.
I didn't vote for George Bush.
I disagreed with a
lot of his policies,
but I thought that was an
incredibly sort of sage
and reasonable reaction.
In the heat of the moment after
9/11 that he did that I thought
was really admirable.
Very stupidly the Taliban said,
no, no, no, they're our guests.
And we went in and got them.
It took a while and we made
a huge number of mistakes,
but that was a war
that made sense to me.
I mean I was over there
in 2000 with Massoud
fighting the Taliban.
I was there in 2001
with his commanders
when they took Kabul, with
the US Air Force overhead.
The Afghans were overjoyed
at what was happening.
We could have done a huge
amount of good there.
We really could have.
We left 15,000 troops
in Afghanistan.
15,000, that's it.
There's 40,000 cops
in New York City.
We left 15,000 American
soldiers in the country
that produced the worst
attack on American soil
since Pearl Harbor.
And we went on to
Iraq, a country
that had nothing to do with it.
And we lost the war in
Afghanistan in Baghdad
basically, in my opinion.
And so the Taliban and
ISIS, what do they share?
In terms of their vision of
Islam and how to run a society,
they're very similar.
ISIS is more extreme, a
little more spectacular
in their brutality, definitely
more media savvy for sure.
But it's the same
radical vision of Islam
that my friend Sarah
Chayes points out.
And Sarah, she's a childhood
friend, former NPR reporter.
When 9/11 happened, she went to
Pakistan, bought a motorcycle,
and drove into Kandahar and
rented a house in Kandahar
while the Taliban were still
in control of Kandahar.
She's also a Harvard graduate,
an incredibly smart woman.
And she really knows
the Arab world.
She learned Pashtun,
really knows
the Arab world, amazing woman.
She wrote a book called
"Thieves of State."
And she examined the
role of corruption.
And what she found was
that the common denominator
in all these radical
Islamic movements that
are so brutal and violent--
the Shabaab in Somalia, Boko
Haram, the Taliban, ISIS--
the common denominator
in all those movements
is that they got traction
in the population
not because the population loved
the idea of radical Islam--
who would really, right?
That's not a fun way to live.
They got traction
because they would
promise to stop the
incredible corruption
of an oppressive regime.
Every one of those
countries was just
crippled with
government corruption.
The governments were basically
criminal cartels that
existed to enrich themselves.
And these radical
movements would say, OK,
if you adopt our
vision of Islam,
we will protect you from the
tyranny of this government
and its corruption.
And people reluctantly would be
like, OK, that's a good deal.
And I remember when I was
in Kabul, Afghanistan,
in the summer of
1996, I got shot
at by a Taliban
machine gun position
on the outskirts of town.
And me and the translator guy
that I-- and he was Afghan.
He was Pashtun-- that
I was working with,
we got behind cover.
We got out of there.
And he said, "We
hate those people.
We hate them.
But we're going to
let them in because we
can no longer live with the
corruption of this government.
And they promised to
clean up corruption."
So if we want to
fight terrorism,
we can fight terrorism
really effectively
by fighting corruption,
particularly corruption
with governments that
we're allied with
and do business with,
particularly those governments.
We won't have to fight terrorism
because it won't gain root.
We're completely
screwing ourselves
and wasting a lot of lives, lot
of lives of very good people.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
That reminds me
of what happen in Iran
with the fall of the shah.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER:
Yeah, of course, yeah.
AUDIENCE: We have
one more question.
AUDIENCE: Follow
up question-- do
you see ISIS changing once
they don't hold territory?
I guess I understand it,
the original ideology
is they are the caliphate.
They're following the Quran.
If they don't hold territory,
they no longer have a mandate.
Is that completely made up or
do you see anything changing?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER:
I mean, I don't
know a regime that doesn't
change the rules of the game
when they lose the game, right?
Including our own
administration.
You lose a vote in
Congress and you just
change what the vote
was about, no problem.
I mean not to pick on
you know who, but I mean,
that's totally human
behavior, right?
So ISIS is going to do that too.
I'd do it.
I mean of course, right?
So yeah, they lose
their mandate,
they'll change the
basis for their mandate
and they'll continue
saying what they
want to say to expand their
power base, of course.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
kind of this rise of corruption
and people wanting to combat it.
But then you also talked
about this tipping point
where there's this point
where it takes not too
much to nudge
people into violence
and then the cascade
to civil war.
How, as you've observed
these, would you define as far
as indicators or warnings
that that tipping
point is beginning to happen?
Because I think anytime
you see corruption
there's people that are
fighting against it.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: I
mean listen, people
might be willing to die but
they're not willing to let
their children die.
And when a population
gets to the point
where there's a reasonable
chance their children will die,
they will do anything.
They will walk across
several international borders
to safety.
They will sell a kidney
on the black market.
They will do absolutely
anything, including
breaking into a
military storehouse
and grabbing a bunch of AKs
and a couple of magazines
and fighting as best they can.
They'll do that.
So where is that tipping point?
The tipping point is
when the security forces
are detaining and torturing and
killing people, particularly
children, when they're
firing heavy machine gun
fire into crowds of protesting
people who are peaceful--
mothers, children, whatever.
When that starts to happen and
if it goes on for too long,
that's the tipping point.
And it would be the tipping
point in this country.
I mean if that happened
in this country,
we'd all be grabbing
weapons, right?
I mean to defend our
families, of course.
I mean, we're the
product of evolution.
We're the products of
individuals that made
certain choices to survive.
We're the product of that.
So of course we would
protect ourselves.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: We
came close to that,
I think, after the
Revolutionary War
during the Whiskey Rebellion
and the debtors crisis,
the Continental
soldiers going out
fighting for the
country and the debtors
coming and taking
their livelihoods,
and then during the Depression,
during the Bonus Army
fight when the military
came after the veterans who
were trying to get their
benefits from World War I.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Yeah
right, absolutely.
Human behavior doesn't
change very much.
AUDIENCE: Hi, how are you doing?
So I have a question.
What are your current thoughts
about the situation that
is happening in Iraq right now
with, they retook the city.
And there's just this huge power
vacuum between the Iraqi Kurds
and with the other people
involved in the government.
What are your thoughts on that?
What's the future for Iraq
looking like right now?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: I
mean, I don't know.
I'm not an expert and I never--
I didn't cover Iraq
because I didn't
think I could be objective.
I mean back in '03 I
was so against the war.
And I wasn't at all against
the war in Afghanistan.
I thought we could do some good.
I was so against
the war in Iraq,
I refused to cover
it because I didn't
think I could be objective.
So I'm not an expert in Iraq.
I'm guessing.
Things tend to slide towards
violence in countries that
are destabilized like that.
And those are obviously
destabilized countries.
And they're also, at this
point, deeply traumatized.
Everyone in those countries has
been exposed to really quite
a lot of violence.
And so I'm guessing.
I'm just going to guess
that that vacuum will
create turf wars
that will trigger
another phase of a regional war.
I hope not, but I
wouldn't be surprised.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Think about
the psychology of the children
since we've been in
Afghanistan since 2001.
Now there's kids who have
been alive for 16 years
and all they've known is war.
Or then with Iraq, all they've
known is war for 14 years.
I mean that must have a--
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Yeah, I
mean, we're almost at the point
where young American soldiers
fighting in Afghanistan
were born after 9/11, that
were not alive on 9/11.
That's pretty amazing.
As far as the
Afghans go, there's
children whose parents
have known nothing but war.
I mean, it's incredible.
And it's not their
fault. They didn't ask
to be invaded by the Soviets.
They didn't ask to have
America load their country full
of weapons and then pull out.
They didn't ask for any of that.
They didn't ask to
have Pakistan arm
and organize and train a
radical Islamic militia
and send it across the borders
as the Taliban to take over.
They didn't ask for any of that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
being here Sebastian.
It's been very
interesting to hear
you speak about this so far.
I just have a question
about the documentary.
And you mentioned the method
was self-documentation.
So I'm assuming
that you and Nick,
seeing the footage
after the fact
and on the cutting
room floor and kind
of going through all of this,
what was that process like?
I imagine it must have
been intense at points
to see certain parts that were
recorded days or weeks after.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER:
Yeah, of course.
Yeah, some of the
footage was upsetting.
But mostly your
job as director is
to create a narrative that's
compelling and provides
a vehicle to communicate
important information.
I don't want it to
just be a history
lesson because people won't
watch the full hundred minutes.
If it's just a series
of personal stories,
you may allow for a human
connection with the viewers,
and that's lovely,
and it's important.
But you also need a
bit of a history lesson
to understand why those humans
are having that experience.
So all the different kinds of
footage we had, from the family
and from the other shooters
we had in the field--
we had access to a kind
of trove of ISIS footage
that ISIS had shot through
some kind of digital backdoor
that I don't understand that
someone sort of found for us.
And so we had access to a sort
of ISIS database of footage
that they shot.
So we had all kinds of stuff.
Some of it's super upsetting.
Some of it was incredibly
motivating and encouraging.
One of the strange things--
my book "Tribe" is about this--
the closer to a front line
you are, the more of a crisis
there is, the better people act.
People within their communities
act incredibly well.
And they act better and better
as things get worse and worse.
And so one of the things
you see in a war zone
is people acting with
unbelievable nobility
and generosity and courage,
I mean just extraordinary,
in a way that they don't
have to in an affluent suburb
like the kind that I grew up in.
I never saw noble
human behavior.
I didn't see any bad
human behavior either,
but I certainly didn't see
any courage or anything.
There wasn't any need
for courage, which
is actually kind of a shame.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: We'll
do two more questions.
I just want to do a question.
Can you talk about the
White Helmets In Syria?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Yeah,
so the White Helmets
were a civil
defense organization
that was organized
sort of organically,
spontaneously to rush into areas
that had been bombed by Assad's
air force, or later
the Russian Air Force,
and dig survivors
out of the rubble
and dig the corpses out of the
rubble to give to the families.
And often those guys
would get killed
because there'd be a second
bombing attack on the same spot
to kill the first responders--
incredibly brave, unbelievably
brave young people doing that.
AUDIENCE: OK, quick
question, I hope.
The first is, is
the war on terror
moving to Africa, as
maybe evident by some
of the recent accounts?
And then secondly, you
mentioned Iraq being a mistake.
Are we on a course
for the same type
of mistake with North Korea?
And perhaps would your team and
company do the same in terms
of gathering information
inside North Korea
like you did with Syria?
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: That
was a short question?
[LAUGHTER]
JORDAN THIBODEAU: We'll give
you 30 minutes to respond.
Go for it.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: I don't know
anything about North Korea
other than what I read
in the paper, which
is the same as what
you read in the paper.
I've got similar
worries I'm sure,
and also maybe an unrealistic
sense that people don't
do, just for the hell of it,
the worst thing imaginable,
like I just have to assume that.
So is the war on terror
moving to North Africa?
I mean, it's been there
for 20 years, right?
I mean the Shabaab--
I mean in 1993, "Blackhawk
Down," Somalia was already--
is that terrorism?
It's an incredibly
troubled place.
The Shabaab is absolutely
a terror organization,
as is Boko Haram.
And Al-Qaeda-affiliated groups
have existed in the Sahara,
in this Sahel for
years and years.
This isn't new.
And of course we don't want
to fight those wars ourselves.
We can't fight everywhere.
But those groups are
legitimate threats.
An al-Qaeda-affiliated group
took over northern Mali
and overran Timbuktu
and destroyed
all these beautiful monuments,
Islamic mosques and things,
like destroyed them, and
killed a lot of the population
and were driven out by French
military action, thank God.
But I mean, that's
an important issue
not just for the
security of the West
but for the dignity and
the safety of the people
who live in those areas.
And so we can't
fight all those wars.
We shouldn't fight
all those wars.
But one thing we can do is have
military trainers and advisors
there to help these
military forces
in those countries that are
often very ill equipped and ill
trained.
You just sort of get
them up to speed so they
can fight their own fights.
That, to me, is a
completely legitimate use
of American power and knowledge.
So no, this isn't new.
And someone asked me about
US forces in those areas
and why are we there, and
someone else said, "Oh,
it's oil interests."
I'm like, come on.
I mean first of all,
you drive a damn car,
so you're not allowed to be
upset about us protecting
oil interests around the
world as long as you're
using that shit, right?
Sorry, that's just
too hypocritical.
But also, that's
ignoring the fact
that these
al-Qaeda-affiliated groups
are incredibly abusive
to the local population.
Just remember that.
They're horrible.
AUDIENCE: So going
back to "Restrepo"
and "Tribe," have
you given any thought
to revisiting the platoon
5, 10, 15 years from now
in the context of "Tribe"?
And possibly a second
question, expanding "Tribe"
into a feature documentary
is super interesting stuff.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER:
Yeah, thank you.
The platoon is not a
platoon anymore, obviously.
It's dispersed.
And most of those guys are
now out of their military
and they're leading their lives.
I don't think I'll
track them down.
I don't know quite how I would--
I don't quite see
the narrative for how
I would make a film about that.
AUDIENCE: Because you
talk a lot about PTSD
and the brotherhood that
comes out of tragic events.
The guys from my platoon
when I was in Iraq,
I feel like the deepest
brotherhood with them
just because we went through
the stuff we went through.
But like my high
school football team,
before I went to Iraq they
were like my brothers, but then
now I won't even go to
a high school reunion--
so in that kind of context.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: I'm not in
touch with all those guys.
I'm close to one guy in
particular that we're
really good friends.
I'm in some kind of contact
with some of the others.
I'm not sure they're in that
much contact with each other
either.
I'm not sure there's
a real story there.
I hear what you're saying.
But I think most
of those guys have
constructed their own
lives and sort of moved on.
A few stayed in the
military, but not many.
If I thought there was story
there, I'd think about it.
But also, I am moving on
from the topic of war,
very deliberately.
"Tribe," obviously a little
part of it is about PTSD,
but mostly it's about our
society and community.
And I'm definitely going to
keep going in that direction.
I can't imagine having
not covered war.
It's part of who I am.
I like to think I've
contributed in a good way
to our country's
conversation about war,
our understanding of war.
I mean, I'd like to think
I've done some good.
The experience has been
sometimes painful but also
extremely positive for me,
having been a war reporter.
But I actually want
to move out of that.
There is a kind of psychological
consequence to engaging
in war, in the topic of war.
It doesn't cost nothing,
psychologically and morally.
And I'm sort of done with it.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Well
thank you for joining
us to talk about the "Hell
on Earth" documentary.
This concludes our first
part of the interview.
But let's give Sebastian a
round of applause for his time.
SEBASTIAN JUNGER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.